how do everybody welcome back for
lipstick diaries today's video that I'm
going to do for you it's about lipstick
but it's about the sort of lipstick that
would be amazing to wear for a festival
as it is festival season now and by the
end of this video I want to know whether
you are team moisture renew or whether
you're team share and shine so firstly
we want to start with a bit of
foundation I've already moisturize my
skin I've woken up a minute M it's dark
I've moisturized my skin I'm then going
to take a little bit of room will wake
me up foundation I'm going to apply that
with a sponge a slightly damp sponge
because I want it to look not too heavy
and we'll work that right the way over
the skin so my foundation is all over
I'm then going to move on to eye shadow
I'm gonna take scandalize this is a
24-hour cream eye shadow I'm gonna work
that all the way over the lid and we
don't want this to look like I've got
tons on I just want it to stay in place
and not be the color of my skin if that
makes sense I want it to show that I've
got something but not too much then I'm
going to run an eye shadow over the top
of it
I've got millionaire eyeshadow I'm gonna
take that with the same brush and just
run it over the top and it's just gonna
add a little bit more of a shine I'm
then gonna take a soft core gel eyeliner
pencil this one is in 0 1 1 sable Brown
and I'm just gonna run that along the
top lash line very slightly so just
buffing the ends of the liner and the
eye shadow kind of become one next for
the brows I've got brow pencil in hazel
and I'm gonna use the end just to brush
the brows through a little bit first and
then shape my brows just slightly then
for concealer I've got wake me up
concealer I've chosen to do the
concealer after I've done the ice just
in case there's any fall down so it will
just nicely clean up under there if
there was a tiny bit
they'll take that around my nose as well
and then I'm gonna take a brush just to
work that I'm then going to take a
Rimmel translucent powder powder that
all interface so that's gonna stay put
for the whole festival and I've gone for
a translucent powder because it's not
going to give too much coverage so I
won't look capes in makeup I'm then
going to pick up a big powder brush and
a natural bronzer and I'm going to
bronze the whole face any areas that the
Sun would here I don't want to look like
I've got loads of contour on I want to
look like I've been on holiday and got a
lovely glow to the skin so on the top
parts of the face any way that the Sun
would hit first so top of the cheekbones
across the nose now it's time for the
lip and time to find out whether you're
a moisture renew or whether you're a
sheering shine kind of girl I'm going to
start off with the moisture renew and I
have got vintage pink now I like this
one a lot I'm gonna pop it straight on
my lip I love this kind of movie taupe
you see how easy it goes on the lip so
for someone who likes to have that kind
of eye catching strikingly this is the
one for you
if Boise you renew is a little bit too
much for you and you want something more
like a lip gloss but look a little bit
less subtle that you can just apply on
the go maybe chitin shines for you
so this lipsticks a little bit more
translucent a little bit more like a lip
gloss it's got vitamins A C and Ian it's
really really nourishing and
moisturizing and it's got an SPF of 20
so then you have the finished festival
look I can't decide if I wish to renew
or if I'm sure will shine I love them
both I think Sheeran shine is easier
probably on the go but who knows you
decide let me know which one is your
favorite I hope you've enjoyed the video
take care and I'll see you can see